ces questions qu'on sait très la belle a
fait un regarde par exemple jusqu'à
obliger de faire l'amour
est-ce que tu prête maintenant la vraie
là là tout de suite sans les caméras est
ce que tu fais ça il en faudrait peu
parce que vous aurez comme je suis
d'accord avec une jolie fille ou avec un
mec très laid avec un extrait n'est
quand même pas bon mais là maintenant tu
me demandes ouais t'es qu'un mec très
laid c'est parce que tu as essayé que
c'est à peu près tous mes beaux parents
regardent ils vont retirer la garde de
l'enfant
oui mais justement alors faire une
question que faire plaisir à tes goûts
par oren ton mec donc ça peut arriver
leur fille sam soir succès l'agp avant d
arriver sur la science fiction toujours
oui j'espère pour toi en tous les cas
alors qu'est-ce que tu choisis tu
discutes avec lui tu lui dis c'est cette
fille tu la connais tu m'aimes tu qu'est
ce que je t'ai fait bon première
solution que c'est une solution tu fais
un truc très spéciale du coni tu sais
que ça lui plaît les 3e - tu te casses
en claquant la porte en disant connard
je préfère la toute première solution
parce que c'est alexis très complètement
pas que tu lui parles de la fille même
si c'est pas vrai avant tu discutes un
jeu alors maintenant on va faire les
moeurs oui comment tu préfèrerais mourir
mais reste vivant en angleterre un stade
tu préférais mourir tué par un skinhead
tué dans un accident d'avion ou tués
dans un stade tout ça est typiquement
anglais
la foule en avion parce que du coup sûr
en soirée dans la légende du rock géants
comme dédié au lit tous les maux
reviennent en avait jusque là on est
allé critique rome du coup dans rain man
justement si tu devais mourir comme une
star du rock tu préférerais mourir comme
otis redding ou buddy holly ou en avion
comme john lennon avec un coup de
revolver dans le ventre comme ça à bout
portant le hijab ces jeunes tout peut
arriver comme janis joplin d'une
overdose non aux lancers et comme le mec
da si d'ici là bonne scott tu sais qui
est mort dans son vomi
alors comme otis redding comme otis
réveille toujours l'avion j'ai tellement
peur en avion tu me dis un jour ça je ne
me prends pas si je le prendrais vont
chaque fois ces genres abord testament
avant et tout ce que tu fais tu bois
n'ont rien suffit mais alors imagine que
le petit adrien que tu meures donc tu es
morte avec corps blanc mais c'est le jeu
c'est morte
le petit adrien il confié dans la merde
non pas l'adage justement ce que tu
préférais qu'il soit confié à france
gall
si le gym à dakar babacar sy il soit
confiée à françoise hardy non invasive
bien près pas suivi vartan ou shellac
sujet fait des classiques dont sheila
sylvie vartan secours parce que vraiment
fort de secours qu'elle fait ce qu'elle
veut dire pour s'attarder j'aime bien
ouais
c'est entre sheila et françoise hardy
quoi ah ouais chellala côté comme ça
rassurant et tout vent puis en ce moment
là pas trop de boulot elle pourrait
sembler bon allez on franchit la
question traditionnelle sont pas si cons
que celles qui ne sont pas content du
tout les questions le vaisseau spatial
fans sont moins cons que hier le
vaisseau spatial ouais je prête
oui bon avec qui tu préférais partir
fais gaffe parce que là tout vers jean
te regarde réfléchit bien tu pars avec
mon max guazini de l'énergie a dû être
fâché avec un accès sûr avec patrice
blanc francard d'europe numéro un
oui avec monique le mars id rtl ou et
catherine lara parce qu'elle est là tout
mais ça va nous aider car sur laquelle
le café et le reste en vigueur jusqu'à
la russie remax parce qu'il est beau
garçon
ouais c'était un fraudeur et wauters a
il est formidable et je ferai pas de
rendez-vous version wii et qu'apprend on
ne peut en faire quand même à quatre ans
avec max guazini max et qu'il y ait
vraiment il est surprenant qu'un garçon
j'apprendrai choix des duos avec les
gens dans l'idaho annoncé jeudi max
parce que monique le marcy parce que
j'aime beaucoup première radio de france
moi j'ai vu des garçons
bon alors entre damas et de la frontière
nouvelles n'ont pas quoi email